To answer this, our variable of interest is the difference of these two things
that has a mean of 10 pounds and its standard deviation is going to be the sum
of this standard deviation and this standard deviation.
Now we need to find out the standard deviation of this. Since variances add, let's work with those.
So the variance of Treatment B is 400/10,000 and the variance of Treatment A is 100.
So if we evaluate this, this will give us the standard deviation of this number.
And it's 0.2236. So we can see the ratio of this to this.
This is much, much greater than the critical value of 1.645.
And so in this case we reject the null hypothesis and therefore accept the alternative.
And there's one particularly interesting feature of these two treatments
as they relate to each other.
Just consider how many people lost weight in each case, and post your thoughts to the forums.